we've been doing a lot of examples where
we just take implicit different and
where we just take implicit derivatives
but we actually haven't calculated we
haven't been calculating the actual
slope of the tangent line at a given
point and that's what i want to do in
this video so what i want to do is
figure out i want to figure out the
slope
the slope
at x
is equal to one so when x is equal to
one as you can imagine once we
implicitly take the derivative of this
we're going to have that as a function
of x and y so it'll be useful to know
what y value we get to when our x is
equal to 1. so let's figure that out
right now so when x is equal to 1 our
relationship right over here becomes 1
squared which is just 1
plus y
minus 1 to the third power is equal to
subtract 1 from both sides you get y
27 it looks like the numbers work out
quite neatly for us take the cube root
of both sides you get y minus 1 is equal
to 3 add 1 to both sides you get y is
equal to 4. so we really want to figure
out the slope at the point 1 comma
1 comma 4 which is right over here when
x is 1
y is 4. so we want to figure out the
slope of the tangent line
right over there so let's start doing
some implicit differentiation
so we're going to take the derivative of
both sides of this relationship or this
equation depending on how you want to
view it and so let's let's skip down
here past the orange so the derivative
with respect to x of x squared is going
to be 2x is going to be 2x and then the
derivative with respect to x of
something to the third power is going to
be 3 times that something it's going to
be 3 times that something squared times
the derivative of that something with
respect to x and so what's the
derivative of this with respect to x
well the derivative of y with respect to
x is just d y
d x and then the derivative of x with
respect to x is just one so we have
minus one and on the right hand side we
just get zero derivative of a constant
is just equal to zero now we need to
solve for d y d x so we get two x
and so if we distribute if we distribute
this business times the d y d x and
times the negative one
when we multiply it times the d d y d x
we get and actually i'm going to write
it over here so we get
plus
plus 3 times y minus x squared
times d y d x
d y d x and then when we multiply it
times the negative 1 we get negative 3
times y
minus x
y minus x 1 be careful y minus x squared
and then of course all of that is going
to be equal to zero
now all we have to do is take this and
put it on the right hand side so we'll
subtract it from both sides of this
equation so on the left hand side
actually all the stuff that's not a d y
d x i'm gonna write in green so on the
left hand side we're just left with 3
times y minus x squared times d y d x
d y the derivative of y with respect to
x is equal to i'm just going to subtract
this from both sides
is equal to
negative 2x plus this so i could write
it as 3
times y minus x squared
plus
sorry minus 2x
so we're adding this to both sides and
we're subtracting this from both sides
minus 2x and then to solve for dydx
we've done this multiple times already
to solve for the derivative of y with
respect to x
the derivative of y
with respect to x is going to be equal
to
3 times y minus x squared minus 2x
all of that over
this stuff
3 times y
minus
x squared and we could leave it just
like that for now so what is the
derivative of y with respect to x what
is the slope of the tangent line when x
is 1 and y is equal to 4 well we just
have to substitute substitute x is equal
to 1 and y equals 4 into this expression
so it's going to be equal to 3 times 4
minus 1
squared minus 2 times 1
all of that over 3 times
minus 1 squared which is equal to
4 minus 1 is 3 you square it you get
9 times 3 is 27 you get 27 minus 2 in
the numerator which is going to be equal
to 25 and then in the denominator you
get 3 times 9 which is 27. so the slope
is 25 27 so it's almost 1 but not quite
and that's actually what it looks like
on this graph and actually just to make
sure you know where i got this graph
this was from wolfram alpha
wool from
well from alpha i should have told you
that from the beginning anyway hopefully
you enjoyed that